[Music]
previously on Deadpool I love you way
too awesome we can fight this you're
right the cancer is only my liver lungs
prostate and brain all things I can live
without what a dude tries to make you a
super slave and kidnaps your future baby
mama I put a lot of rolls
damsel-in-distress ain't one of them
it's time to be a superhero
it's a face I'd be happy to sit on
they're all caught up
[Music]
oh you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care auditor strong highs
beautiful girlfriend
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in a
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again kiss me like you missed me read
what in the ass
my name's cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid movie guy
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be you need you lot smarter
than I look
I am lettin cable kill this kid I can't
do this alone
we're gonna form a super-duper group
that's what we're gonna be
forward-thinking
gender neutral you will be known as
x-force isn't that a little derivative
you're absolutely right now cue the
music
tell me they got that in slow motion
you're the right thing is messy you want
to fight for what's right dirty that is
why the man bun is just a millennial
mullet oh god I wish I finished college
it lives up to the hype
plus plus they probably won't even make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it
[Music]